let's go next to our caller from the
eight for seven area code who's calling
today from eight four seven hey David
this is Joey I'm calling from Chicago
hey Joey what's going on
how much Matt's on the first off say I
appreciate your show so much thank you
hey yeah watch you guys everyday anyways
um I want to talk about social media so
I forgive me if I you know ask something
that you already answered in shows they
were you were talking that's a lot but I
watched your tympole debate okay and so
you know I'm 32 so I remember what is
social media started and it's just kind
of crazy how it like evolved and now
there's you know all this debate on
obviously free speech when you know in
reality when you have white supremacists
or you have somebody you know touting
you know anti-semitic stuffer and any
any racist stuff any rational person
will be like me okay that's wrong
what is it what is stopping you know
Twitter Facebook or whatever from kind
of just being like no not just saying
there on the left but just being like
we're not going to accept this you know
what I mean what I don't understand
what's stopping who from saying what to
whom well because I feel like Twitter
and like the bigger social media places
are like kind of trying to they kind of
have to like tiptoe around well yeah
they're trying to not appear to be
making editorial decisions that are
overtly politically biased right and I
understand that but what my question I
guess is just what is stopping them to
stopping them from not becoming a little
politically biased okay so you're saying
like why so if Twitter says yeah we have
a left-wing bent or we have a right-wing
bent what white why would that be bad
why can't they just do that like it's
okay for companies to have political
bends is what you're suggesting yeah
yeah I mean I think the problem is that
these platforms have gotten so big that
if they just say we're just a little
company
we're a conservative company it will
immediately open them up to more
lawsuits than they're already facing
arguments that they should be regulated
because of their size and that it would
be inappropriate that it that that any
limitation on speech that is politically
biased should be handled as if they are
sort of pseudo government entities we
under these Town Square sort of ideas
and provisions so I think that there are
very clear reasons why they would want
to be perceived as not even if the
individuals who run the companies have
personal politics which of course they
do what they would want to appear as
though the editorial decisions they make
and the content decisions are not
politically biased I get why they want
to do that yeah
yeah I think you know it's just getting
to like this crazy extent where you know
obviously anybody can say whatever they
want but I mean and it's like you but
just to was like how demeaning can you
be to a certain group of people and it
just be free speech obviously you know
yes well I mean from a legal standpoint
we know where the line is when it comes
to the terms of service of a private
company there are more factors to
consider including where the company is
drawing the line right cool all right
appreciate it yep great to hear from you
Joey Joey from Chicago